was mir allerdings auffällt in der
debatte ist das ist immer eine größere
diskriminierung muss man fast sagen von
ungeimpften gibt und damit meine ich
jetzt nicht ausschließlich maßnahmen
sondern wenn ich mir die diskussionen
anschauen diese momentan gibt um joshua
king mit sarah wagenknecht richard david
precht die einfach nur fragen gestellt
haben die möglicherweise aus sicht
anderer menschen jetzt nicht so klug
waren die sich aber millionen menschen
stellen dann macht mir das sorge um die
meinungsfreiheit in deutschland dass man
diese fragen so scheint es zumindest
nicht offen diskutieren kann ohne einen
wahnsinnigen beck flash zu bekommen also
ohne dann platt gemacht zu werden und
damit meine ich jetzt nicht eine normale
diskussion wie man sich das in den
sozialen medien anschaut dann ist das
wie ja ein maulkorb oder verteilt werden
soll und eine hetzjagd die stattfindet
und das finde ich problematisch da sieht
man was diese anderthalb jahre pandemie
bereits mit uns gemacht haben was das
mit der meinungsfreiheit auch in
deutschland gemacht selbst